hey guys mayor here the game spot news
update it looks like the Xbox one is
getting a major update in November and
Microsoft is letting members of the xbox
one preview program check it out the new
xbox one experience which is powered by
Windows 10 is Xbox one's biggest update
so far with the most major change being
xbox 360 backwards compatibility the
update completely overhauls the home
screen to make it faster and easier
there will be a new community section to
make the console more social as well as
updates to the Xbox tour due to the size
and significance of the update Microsoft
is slowly rolling out access to preview
program members beginning with people
who have historically submitted the most
feedback over time they plan to include
more people if you're not in preview
program you may be out of luck microsoft
recently scaled back the volume of
invitations as the program is nearing
capacity for the latest news on xbox one
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot com